hey what's up guys thanks for tuning in
to are you garbage please make sure you
go subscribe to the youtube channel that
way you get the videos as they come out
yeah
do it
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley hey everybody out there welcome
back to everybody's favorite new podcast
this is are you garbage it's the show
where we sit down with your favorite
comedians to find out they grew up
classy or just a big old piece of [ __ ]
i'm your host holy coming at you on a
beautiful day here down here aunt
cootie's basement sitting around the
table chopping it up with the boys my
best pal in the whole world is sitting
right [ __ ] next to me my knee is
touching his thigh yeah and it's
twitching because the kid is not calm
cool and collected a little bit of
anxiety yeah kippy kevin james ryan
ladies and gentlemen hey gang happy to
be here i really do not like the fact
that we're touching uh guys make sure
you please rate review subscribe on
itunes video available on youtube yeah
subscribe there as well also
patreon.comru garbage uh you can sign up
for uh bonus content bonus episodes
videos at the end of every month we're
going to be doing a live stream with you
guys that sign up for it look out uh you
know you get to ask us questions we're
gonna be asking you questions it's a
whole [ __ ] scene also podcast
merch.com get yourself a [ __ ] t-shirt
let's go and the ru garbage card game is
now out i hope
so get that the link will be in the
description just in time for the [ __ ]
holidays and gang don't forget december
10th we're going to be in royersford pa
the announcement so there's a lot of
them co-headlining and soul joel's
comedy club also have seven o'clock
let's get it all out now we're in the
fourth quarter of the season here guys i
gotta make a little bit of games
let's go those christmas trees are
coming up low on the bottom i'll tell
you that empty boxes all around it's
like a department store at the foley
household real quick let's tip our hats
to our producer extraordinaire they're
very funny the very
very talented mr toby mcmullen t-bone
my man we love you pal and that's
neither here nor there because we
couldn't be more excited to have our
incredibly special incredibly requested
guest here with us today i think it's
going to be a real fun one you know this
gentleman from you up with nikki glazer
in his own podcast called puddles i
slept on his kitchen floor in bushwick
for six months quit bragging we caught
ourselves roommates we hung out watched
tv together talked about life learned
lessons it was fantastic i'm telling you
off the bat i know he comes from a
little bit of cash but this kid's
straight trash
he's
garbage you just you have like guy who
smoked too many you've you've seen some
chick face
andrew collins ladies and gentlemen oh
[ __ ] i remember stepping over your dead
body
every day to go to work and i'm like
what are you doing full he's like i i'm
a waiter and i was like yeah right
yeah or you've been dead for six months
and then and then you just go you just
go
like like a bear like a bear like that's
woken up before his hibernation's over
he's just like this guy sleeps tense
daddy no oh yeah comes out of a
nightmare every time oh every time man
but then i saw you in that like french
restaurant in the west village and
you're an amazing waiter like you were
incredible like did you live there did i
live no i walked the dog by there oh
that's right that's right
it was a nice dog oh you were working at
that restaurant sleeping on my floor i
was walking a dog you remember i just
remembered
i remember me and you hanging out
watching basic cable like playing around
with everybody else
that house was a [ __ ] we lived next
to that drug dealer named the king yeah
and then one guy just disappeared and we
never looked into it
he only asks questions around here all
right
there's some indian guy who thought he
was like he moved there and he he came
from a decent family i think and he's
like oh no now i'm a hood rat and i'll
hang out with the neighbors and they
just disappeared and i swear
yeah yeah yeah
i love that guy oh dude there's a great
documentary on hulu i watched fantastic
i watched
all about six nights great marketing
yeah kid knew what he was doing next
episode we're gonna both be in red
bandanas
like i did a couple of face tattoos and
some downloads you know what i'm saying
all right let's get into it uh i want to
hear the backstory of andrew collins
you're a southern boy i think right
florida which a lot of people who don't
say is something he comes it's very
annoying yes it's like a fan of
respected family you want to say i come
from money fully this guy this guy fell
off the back of the
back of the [ __ ] i fell off the boat
and i landed on a [ __ ] twin bike from
1946. yes i imagine you i grew up rich
and you were a nightmare i started from
the top and i fell before you yeah no my
dad's a doctor he's an oncologist a
cancer doctor that's a pretty good cage
especially in florida
no he's great at finding tumors i don't
know that's all i know it's like that
dog that sniffs them out did your mom
work growing up dessert yeah there is
dude oh yeah there is a dog that does
that orange if you have cancer
what if you get like you're walking in
the airport he's smelling like nah i
swear to god it's [ __ ] lung cancer
i swear to god i don't even smoke weed
anymore dude that's a guy you put coke
in his ass like no i'll show
[Laughter]
somebody give me cancer quick move some
product in here that's just blow to the
movie
[Laughter]
we started out as a cancer award um
all right he's an oncologist he's an
oncologist where in florida did you grow
up well i grew up i was born in miami my
dad's from queens okay and my mom's from
chicago they met in chicago uh and then
they moved to miami my dad did his
residency at jackson hospital and i was
born in miami i only lived there two
years and then we moved to this kind of
back then it was a smaller town called
port st lucie florida okay i think i've
heard of it met spring training sure
and uh yeah it went from like you know
12 000 people to 200 000 over what a lot
of cancer patients it was great for my
dad yeah in the eighties
yeah i mean so we know we're fueling the
whole growth of this cancer yes cancer
and cocaine yeah which go hand in hand
yeah well c and c
factory hey cancer cocaine
factory um yeah so we grew up there it
was kind of a small town i was like the
only jew and like the whole you're
jewish i'm sorry oh no i wouldn't ever
know i would have never invited you well
thanks for coming by
yeah
i know i feel scared in a basement i
paid you for it
really yeah really i know you knew you
were jewish now now i cannot see it it's
like it's like one of those 3d puzzles
once you know where waldo is you can
pick them out right away the matching
sweatsuit starts to pull things together
a little bit doesn't it yeah my dad's a
cancer all right
no so yeah so we grew up there uh nice
house
uh you know doctors i i'm not gonna say
it is a little weird doctors get rich
later yes
they go through a lot of schooling yeah
i think they deserve their paycheck
you know like you know it's like it's
not like he just sold one house or
something like the guy saved a lot of
lives
one big operation rolls off the
residuals
[Laughter]
i did a heart transplant in 88. i get a
check every month you know what my dad
would do he just cut out a little of the
tumor and then keep it going for years
smart
real jew
is that what you want is that what you
always want
he's a dirty heap is that what you want
and did your mom work huh no [ __ ] i'm
[ __ ] married to a doctor
she worked a little in the office i
don't remember her working she uh she
she had a a company called rooms by
robin which was a interior design
company for about three days yeah that
sounds like that sounds like a rich
wife's thing yeah it's a hobby yes that
was talked about at a couple dinner
parties and yeah the sequin hats that
she made came out
and yeah everybody was ever a couple of
bottles of wine deep like ruins by robin
it rolls right off the top
i can see the business cards now oh she
made business oh of course yeah it was
the 80s
every dude if you have a business card
in the 80s you were a [ __ ] dad paid
for the whole thing
of course he did never saw a dime so my
mom i don't think she was raising
outside funds for rooms by robin yeah i
mean it's probably why he cheated
there we go
first bombshell of the episode coming in
early right away
and then married the [ __ ]
so they got divorced no yeah yeah yeah
that must have been a hell of a doctor
i'll tell you that
wait when you say she worked at the
office the office wasn't at the house
wasn't it no yeah my dad worked out an
oncologist
redid the shed what are you talking
about
well doctors at the suburbs he's jumping
out and he's in the pool right next to
us
don't mind the kids now let's see your
tips
don't mind the kids but i got some bad
news
the best get out of here good news is
you can stay for dinner
the bad news is you got to get off the
couch because the kids got to sit down
yeah no i uh yeah so no yeah she worked
in the office my dad started like a
private practice when he moved there he
was like the only cancer doc there was
like one other guy that kind of did
cancer gotcha and that and fireworks so
my dad moved like to the middle of
nowhere essentially there you go
queens being from new york my mom didn't
want to move there so that probably
started the unhappiness okay you know uh
our temple one time i'm not a big jew
you know but back then we brought it up
nine times already
[Laughter]
i know your audience i'm trying to get a
table at a restaurant over here i want
them to turn it off as fast as possible
no but like they put swastikas all over
that's how they asked me to prom yeah it
was cool
dude florida is something else yeah i
don't even know if it was skin i guess
it was skinheads you know i mean it was
it wasn't the
there were shriners
everywhere there was died 6 million left
which was kind of witty
and i remember i brought my irish or my
italian catholic friend he's like is
this is this all the time and i was like
nah just for you oh just for you you
brought him to the temple then though
it happened to be the one day that they
swatched to cut it up and he was just
like
like yeah and i mean less sleep over at
the colin house
i had a lot of guys right before the
hate crimes started
so many hate crimes growing up and it
came from their parents you know like i
don't know where the [ __ ] you came from
sure you know i mean they had i remember
when walking in my one buddies had mine
comp like nine different copies
okay you know this is pretty good
paperback and hard copy that scratch and
sniff you could actually smell the dead
jews it was pretty cool that's funny
because the area i grew up in was so
like when i was born in upstate
pennsylvania and that was like [ __ ]
1950 but when we moved down outside of
philly it was such an eclectic you know
temples catholic churches you know uh
muslims everybody was mixed in korean it
was it was crazy yeah we used to live a
little bit of that life and i couldn't
imagine if i went over to beth or temple
to go to temple with one of my friends
and we were going to [ __ ] have a nice
dinner afterwards and i saw that [ __ ] on
the wall it would ruin the evening i'll
tell you that it was i see him i grew up
with my whole neighborhood was jewish
like half the cafe went to school with
her all yeah everybody was i mean it was
like nine thousand bar mitzvahs i went
through should have been over in boca or
something like that yeah i know anytime
i say i'm from florida i'm jewish oh
really oh is that hard a little new york
south and i'm like [ __ ] you [ __ ] yeah i
got stabbed [ __ ] poe dunkville yeah
well let's ask mike mahoney who walked
into a cross burning it's always been my
environments the people that didn't grow
i always just thought you grew up like i
just thought they were it was just
regular everybody grow but jews you
don't realize that in most of the
country there's not a lot of jewish
people it's really it's really like so
that was a thing yeah it definitely was
a thing right did your house ever get
vandalized or anything uh
oh yeah what is an insurance scam yeah
come on someone had the wife's jewish
come on and we had to pay for the
radiation in the living room
no uh no there was not like none of that
but that would suck no but one of my
buddies i remember he lit us again a
swastika but on fire like with uh
swastikas are big yeah i don't know if
they know what they are they don't they
just think they're cool yeah when little
kids do that [ __ ] you're like you're a
[ __ ] idiot yeah and i remember but it
was like a good friend so he let it on
fire yeah he lit on fire and then he and
then he shot a bb gun at me under the uh
bathroom uh door and he's like it died
you while listening to uh tool and i was
like this is uh and then he wrote me 20
years later
apologizing
because he went into rehab and he's like
oh you know i'm a vegan now i'm my
life's better
yeah getting the dancer
shooting at you wait i like you better
as soon as hitler wait he wasn't your
friend what do you mean you were friends
we were good for you know these friends
that just destroy you but you're like oh
they take they'd fight for me you know
these friends when was the burning of
the swastika and bb gun incident what
grade probably eighth grade i would say
jesus jesus but i make it sound bad
there were good like i i like how to
make it sound bad you had a hate crime
kind of painted in a dark picture today
we had some good times too
not every day you know i would skip
school
[Laughter]
i would you know
those were the good things
no yeah no sometimes you get a stomach
bug you don't go for three days but i
went because my dad had some money my
mom wanted us to go to a private school
nice so i went to private this place
called saint edwards and vero beach
florida and we would travel an hour to
school every day jesus how'd you get
that your mom drive you or did you bust
it bust it so they would go collect like
the people from yeah they collected
juice
they would drop off some not at school i
don't know where they were going no no
that's not what i was saying yes you
were they put us on a trolley and burn
us
is that what you want why would you take
a yellow bus or would it be like a nice
place no it was blue for june
let everybody know on the highway
that's [ __ ] up no because my buddy
went to a private school that was like
far away as well and he would have the
bus would come get him at like three in
the morning like they said it had to go
pick up everybody in like a 50 mile
radius it was insane you had to get yeah
it was an hour to school about an hour
five and i played sports so like jeez so
like you wake up six a.m this is why i'm
lazy now you know because i did it all
by seventh grade yeah
i was [ __ ] pulling 18 hour days as a
nine nine year old
i played three sports so i'd leave at
seven in the morning i'm not back till 7
30 at night sure you know what i mean
just [ __ ] and then you can eat a lot
yeah yeah you eat alone and you're just
like [ __ ] you can microwave food
alone my mom's drunk you know
[ __ ] alcoholics dad's getting cold
dads getting laid on the other side of
town by a waspy woman with [ __ ] huge
tits
my dad sent the picture of my mom in a
bubble bath
not like a year ago to the [ __ ]
[ __ ] your mom or your stepmom of my
stepmom okay i was like yeah good thanks
you know how old is she younger
she should have went younger he could
have went you could have went younger
she had three kids so oh yeah yeah and
they worked at the same office together
all the kids yes no no no no no no no
the girl yeah yeah the woman worked
there oh really she was a sex character
same thing with my dad did she work
there while your mom worked there no
because my mom you know was only there a
day and then started rooms by robin
she had her own things going on
a couple bottles of pinot and rooms by
robin
really honestly yeah that's pretty much
it so how did how many brothers and
sisters i have two brothers and then
three step siblings uh now yeah are you
close to the steps growing up it was
just the two brothers i don't even know
their names huh growing up it was just
the two brothers yeah pretty much what
did the affair happen and when did he
get busted ah [ __ ] i still remember like
it was yesterday so yesterday
no so
man i got a call for bruh we're not even
into it i can tell you're a real [ __ ]
dirtbag
like joke so anyway so yesterday
i'd love to know how many dinners he's
ruined growing up a lot of silence going
too far uh so so
so uh
yeah no i think i was i got they got
divorced at 13.
they found out around 12
were you aware of any of this where you
sheltered from it oh i was yeah i was
[ __ ] they don't know what i told her
[Laughter]
she had rooms for robin money
i was a cuck early on
no no no it doesn't seem like they keep
a lot of secrets to be honest with you
what are you talking about you asked for
the story yeah we want it i know what
i'm just saying i'm sorry i come in high
i love it but nobody
a tight-lipped family doesn't produce
this this guy's letting it all hang out
let it hang so 12 14. so i was like 12
and i remember the the husband of the
wife
that he cheated on called my mom god
damn it yeah and he found out about how
he said she was married had kids yeah
yeah she worked at the office though
sparks started flying one thing led to
another yeah and uh my dad looked for a
tumor inside her [ __ ]
it was an exam
i loved
she had a referral what do you want me
to do
i had to take her
look the dog smelled it so
so one night the goddamn dog but it's
not barking at her i said let me take a
look at that thing i love this dog this
cancer there is a cancer dog what a sad
life he's like a beagle or something
he's like i just want to live no good
news i just want to run everyone hates
him because he's always telling people
get him the [ __ ]
nobody ever likes him that's great
the other dogs don't trust them the
lottery barks don't farther along it it
is um no so yeah 13 phone call one night
and i remember they sat us down and
you don't remember the phone call was it
was it rocky before it was rock it
wasn't like yeah i'm just asking i don't
know it was like sometimes they can you
know it was bad at least keep up
appearances like for a year i would say
like two years i'm not even [ __ ] with
you every night it was like it's
impressive almost when you think about
it but every night
they're screaming at each other [ __ ]
[ __ ] you you ain't [ __ ] and i'm in my
room you know watching boys
basketball
you ain't [ __ ] [ __ ]
she dunks on him
and one [ __ ]
yeah
it's wet they're in the driveway
settling the score i wish it was just
basketball
that's crying
yes yes so then you know i've been able
to play a game all or since
this was great this was great about the
divorce so they so they're getting
all they love that they're separated
right wait hold on take me to when they
sat you down oh they sat me down my
mom's crying on the floor
um whatever you know being annoying
floors by robin that's why you're in
this spot honey
look she picked them out
it's nice linoleum there
[Laughter]
she's crying
the floors don't match the wall floors
by robin tears by andrew he's just
balling his eyes out
and so whatever and then yeah he's like
you know i'm gonna move out i'm moving
to a condo
and then he moved to a condo and you
know did he ask if you want to come with
does anybody know he kind of knew that
he was losing this one you know when you
cheat you don't have an upper hand yeah
he could say look i make all the money i
pay for the kids schooling i paid for
your jaguar but you know you cheat
you're [ __ ] hold on it's jaguar by the
way
whatever the hell what's that your new
money he had
to go through a couple of what's the
name of the car
he had a mercedes
had a mercedes-benz a jaguar
i don't know sometimes it comes out you
know
but that's a good guy that's classy he
you know he yeah sounds like a great guy
well i'm just sorry yeah
i mean you won't you leave committed
adultery cheetah i ruined it but she'll
leave the two houses apart you leave the
house and the family with the with the
wife and the kids yes yeah yeah so he's
like i put him in a [ __ ] condo by the
airport no we had a nice house too we're
not gonna say his condo and my dad had
one diet pepsi
and like a half a pizza box and he ate
them paper like that's what a divorce
anybody want to come with me today we're
like dude get the [ __ ] out of here i'll
walk you out yeah
i'll see you out but i'm not [ __ ]
leaving my crib i got all my [ __ ]
[ __ ] here my [ __ ] ghost
house four four forty years [ __ ] do you
got a gt bike at your place yeah yo we
got a go-kart outside [ __ ] can
you fit that in your trunk you see that
pantry [ __ ] i'm staying here dude i'm
going there
yeah so then how many unfinished guest
rooms out of sleeping in his house oh
man he was moving all the way dude those
[ __ ] beds oh divorce dad's bed in the
second the second room at a divorce
dad's house is so
no it's never finished
it's on like wheels it like moves around
because he knows he's gonna move again
that's tough and like you try to jerk me
off on it and you fall off the wall like
it goes against the end up in the
hallway there's an exercise bike right
next to it and always ironing it's not
hooked up it doesn't even turn on yeah
yeah divorce dad's rule
that's why you have to get a wife that's
why he married the woman because he
couldn't do anything on his own you know
other than you know save lives so how
long was it
other than sniff out cancer
oh man so that's what i'm competing
against here you know your dad's i mean
i'm sure your dads were
losers talked to him in six years great
guy
degenerate
guy
yeah i had to compete against my dad
abandoned us when i was 27. think about
that
is that possible i don't know he stopped
answering
you that sounds
you're an adult man
you got to let it get up i have i
it's not like i drive by his house
anymore dad
he just went you know how bad he hated
you yeah oh yeah i say that about my dad
my dad was unbelievable and there were
so many times when i looked back and i
can't believe he didn't he didn't he
didn't leave just just from the torture
that me and my brother put them through
yeah just fighting and just being
bastards to each other breaking [ __ ]
ruining everything that they got i don't
know how he didn't just get in the car
one day and never come back i mean you
know probably have a hot secretive yeah
he was a secretary he probably yeah
if i know you i know your dad didn't
have many choices yeah yeah
he had a great job
he's like no dude my dad
yeah
i do love you buddy no he's watching
right now yeah from uh below
[Laughter]
watch it from hell
dog didn't get them in time he just
seems at the bottom of our feet
yeah so anyways yeah that was pretty
much it and then
he moved out and then
he ended up no so what was funny is i
had a bar mitzvah my friends had no idea
what it was sure did you clean up
seven grand i bought a used jet ski i
spent every dollar i didn't even have
gas how could you be new money at 13.
[ __ ] that's insane new money 13 buy
the jets dropped seven large i bought a
yamaha three-seater i only had one
friend
i was like come on what are we doing
here who are we lying save room for the
town races
yeah yeah right [ __ ]
that's that might be that's like a
that's an insane thing to do
just buy it yeah i mean it's trash to
buy one as an adult but as a [ __ ] why
are my parents letting i'm going to true
first of all i shouldn't i should invest
at least two grand of it i'm surprised i
didn't take half of that they probably
did the catholics they take the whole
lot really yeah we have our our version
is communion okay
i remember making like over a thousand
bucks right that's a lot my mom took it
all i made 200 never saw there's some
jews in long island that make like 70
grand my friends growing up
his parents must have spent 100 grand on
this thing they had a huge like wall
sized neon sign made that said hats off
to derek it was black tie
it was black tie catered derrick is
there jewish name
derek full of your idea of what a
hundred grand is
look they misspelled derek
they had the whole you know how like
there's a step up they had the whole the
whole bar area they had
people even knocked on the door they
told them get out of here till 7pm they
had them little swords for the cherries
it was crazy oh that was class back oh
you got a shirley temple with a sword in
it i turned into zero oh i turned into
zorro real [ __ ] good night you just
bought an extra half hour at the table
they had seven balloons
it was great they didn't didn't even
float nothing compared to communions
though no no no no no and you got seven
i got seven which isn't bad [ __ ]
honor you just don't
14 and i've been looking for it ever
since i go back to my mom's house and
dig through the closets ah i could have
turned the whole thing around oh man if
i had that hundred bills bro i'd be a
different kipper that's like 12 grand
now well i asked my dad yeah
inflation right and canadian how many
how much bitcoin is that
i would dude if i had that hundred bucks
i would have gotten a bitcoin early real
early yeah if i can do
what it is
i i don't even i don't even know what
happened to jet ski to be honest i
really don't i asked my dad yeah i was
like what did we do with that you know
he wasn't there but whatever
i'm talking in an empty guest room
he's working
so yeah so then um after that i don't
know my dad remarried my dad married my
stepmom at mar largo and that crazy ah
this guy's got a little bit of keys i'm
so poor i can't wrap my head around what
mar largo is that's not how you say it
is it one house
but because he's go he lives there who
trump yeah i thought you met my dad yeah
yeah pretty sweet no but trump is that a
resort it's a it's a private residence
that's probably i don't know how many
probably like 15 acres i'm guessing okay
it's big it goes from ocean to river on
like palm beach island he bought it it
was like his best investment ever he
bought it for like a couple i thought it
was about now it's worth 40 million it's
not uh is there a golf course there no
there might be like one like small hole
i don't really remember so it's a
private residence that they rent out for
weddings and [ __ ] yeah i think my dad's
like the first wedding that had to be
expensive yeah i was like this is
interesting did your mom go
uh she watched from canoe
she watched for my jet ski
she watched the guys at the giants games
yeah
waiting for the corsage
he's going to cheat on her too scumbag
oh where did they where did your mom
grow it farther
where'd your mom and dad get married not
[ __ ] mara largo no no you've said it
three different times it's been wrong
not marlboro miles
not marlboro
[Laughter]
mar-a-lago now they got me [ __ ] up
mar-a-lago i don't even know doesn't
matter we ain't never gonna be there
marlboros we're never getting the table
[Laughter]
i remember not with your cool new jacket
on
but yeah so yeah we were there and uh i
don't even really like yeah the wedding
was nice i guess i
at that time trump wasn't trump yeah
he was just a guy that was pretty
[ __ ] cool back then i mean whatever
and uh and uh yeah i don't know so then
they got married my stepbrother moved in
they got a townhouse my stepbrother
moved in my stepbrother jake jake the
snake okay and he's he's uh he's as
florida as i should show you really i'll
i'll show you a photo after yeah yeah
yeah he is forced
and this was a step up for her she was a
receptionist at a doctor's office now
she's got the doctor
i didn't even think of that wow
she's spending some she's not she's not
jewish no
no she's the one that sprays it
i was like why do you have spray paint
on your hands genie
[Laughter]
and that's how they found each other
loving hate is very good ah that's too
funny no so and they oh i'm sorry are
they still together yeah and you're
you're you're you're your stepmother and
your dad they are they are they are so
they must have turned on the spending
once they got into the castle huh yeah
yeah a little bit but now one time my
brother my dad bought a boat right he
bought a a jupiter or a um not a jew
whatever one of these nice center
console boats probably 70 grand like an
expensive boat okay center console nice
yeah i i you know i'm from my my dad's
from new york my mom's from chicago
we're not like a big like you won't find
me in the mangroves in florida you know
but my step-brother he is a mangrove you
know he's on a walking alligator he's
still i just picture i picture him in a
sleep i picture him like larry the cable
guy i don't know why no he's skinnier he
kind of looks like he could be like in
bloodline but he just works on the dock
okay he doesn't have a talking roll
he's a deckhand
he's stolen a couple of crab traps in
his day he lives in a crap trap yeah
yeah
he's not adverse to stealing a lobster
he sells he knows his way around a
crustacean i'll tell you that much
i got hot we got hot lobster hot dogs um
yeah so uh
no no i remember i was like i remember
this was like later in my life and i was
just like hey i want to take the boat
out he's like you can't take it out
without the captain and i'm just like
who the [ __ ] you're the captain of my
dad's boat i can't use my dad you're
brought your stepbrother brother oh the
captain i would have fought him anybody
that refers to themselves especially if
you bring in some girls man
you gotta let me get out there jake's
gotta get a taste
okay
he loved his puzzles he'd get mad if i
went near his puzzles that was another
thing about him he's like you're going
near my puzzle
like when i was younger we would do
wednesdays every other weekend that kind
of thing wednesday my dad didn't have a
good lawyer duty wednesdays every other
weekend
jesus is like six hours a week that's
the night nypd
yeah good school he didn't want him yes
yeah he was the best lawyer ever well
it's also at that point it's like
wednesday's a little much he's good he's
gonna think he fought for you wednesdays
[ __ ] god damn it wednesdays
how long was the divorce the hearings
long no
they kind of rolled over real quick
actually they go wednesday all right
that's it
take it um
uh that it it's always tricky too
because i know with my same thing my dad
had some cash when they got divorced and
uh
same thing the the younger
woman from the office moving oh really
same thing same exact thing and uh
they start spending some cash she's
known at his mom's house as the who is
she no no no no no um they're no longer
together anyway uh
things aren't real
how would you know yeah sure they
couldn't sit outside thanksgiving he's
blocked you on everything including real
life
but with the mom that because now your
dad's gonna cut money your mom your
dad's gonna give money to your mom every
month so then he's she's going you
bought a [ __ ] ball it's like she's
now aware of the spending sure that
heroin the new wife that him and the new
wife are spending having a good time
over there and you're just sitting there
trying to get your [ __ ] chicken
fingers like you know what my dad would
do you know what my dad would do he'd
have my stepmom cut the check
so every day she's writing this big
check to my mom and then this guy's
diabolical wow he's like i'm saving
lives i can do whatever the [ __ ] i want
he's a king yeah he's a [ __ ] honestly
they would call like i remember going
into his office and people be like your
father saved my mother like he was
treated like that's awesome yeah i mean
it was pretty cool like you know my dad
is our relationship now is actually way
better than yours
but here's the thing that's the way i
look at it if they you know he does have
this job okay that's not a regular job
he's saving people's lives i know
there's a lot of money involved in it
but you don't really get into that [ __ ]
for the money per se to a degree you're
trying to be a doctor to save people's
lives it's a nice after effect but if
he's at home getting his [ __ ] balls
broken there's fighting and yelling i
mean push comes to shove what's gonna
happen
i mean i think he's i'm saying so you
can't be that man it's not like you have
a grudge against him no i mean i did for
a long time when you live what are you
talking about no no no no i get what
he's i get what i'm saying but nothing
now you see your father as a human and
not this monster that just cheated and
there's way less emotional investment in
them you're like i don't really care you
get older and you cheat and you learn
how to cheat and you realize that you're
dead you get a boat
yeah no but you realize like okay people
yeah they're human yeah they're human
yeah we're human and uh and you know my
and like i didn't know the guy i said
you know you know we never had
conversate like i didn't but now we talk
like now like i don't know it's great
now um but yeah back then you just see
him as this like this character your mom
draws sure sure yeah yeah i'm sure she
wasn't
oh she wasn't thrilled yeah no no no you
heard it every day when you were living
with her yeah it was bad but she got the
house
she got the house which had a balloon
mortgage so then she had to sell yeah it
was cool
upside down yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's pretty hard yeah oh i'm
sure yeah keep the house no problem yeah
should see it see you in three years
yeah all right so you want the house and
i only get them on wednesdays all right
i guess so i guess
what do i sign all right play the
lottery after that you got a high hand
yeah he drives away like no and then
right down the street he just says
you hear the radio turn up
[Laughter]
and like that
he was gone he just
he drives an old piece of [ __ ] car gets
throws a match in that thing and burns
takes his watching his wallet off keeps
walking
yeah no i mean but yeah so i mean that
was pretty much my childhood sounds
great and then where was this yeah
where did you go from there where'd you
go to school you're broke because your
brother does well doesn't he yes he does
he uh what's he do for a living he's a
does private equity fun
so it's like richard gere in scent of a
woman yeah pretty woman oh yeah you're
the second person to compare somebody
yeah
said her dad was richard here and a
pretty woman
my
wife look my brother how much to stay
tonight
the whole night how bad would you
[ __ ] feel if my brother [ __ ] had a
grenade in his hand and it [ __ ] took
out his eyes how bad would you feel
and i was actually right i couldn't
drive a stick and i saw it on the road
anyways he was like al pacino
yeah we're gonna win this game yeah
we're gonna get him on the goal and
we're not gonna no that's rudy okay
a game of inches that's what that
species that's a great speech i love a
good [ __ ] sports any given sunday is
very underrated that's a great thing
it's a it's real [ __ ] hammy but it's
our yeah it's all right
also is it underrated when people say
these things i i don't understand these
ratings you know you can throw that out
sometimes too that's real underrated no
one ever goes yeah is it actually it's
quite rated for what it is actually they
actually did okay on the budget
moderately rated they made their money
back they had mixed reviews and it did
okay domestically i mean people say that
about like bill burton they're like bill
burr most underrated community it's like
underrated the guy has 20 million
dollars
what are we talking about how many jet
skis is that
a lot of use jets if i do the
so your brother's done well so my
brother did very well my brother is this
square can i ask you is this where the
house in the hamptons comes in yes okay
yes because i see
you
you're one of you can operate in that
world i could see you you put on a nice
pair of [ __ ] salmon pants and a duck
belt put a [ __ ] eyes on on i could
see you hobnobbing at these yeah fancy
eyes on yes but then i think you wanted
him yeah i know he's like look at you i
can see you put it on
[Laughter]
but then you also know what guy that
works with the catering company and
walked up and doing it where do i get a
20 bag later on i think that's a great i
think it's great
it's not just a skill i think it's like
i really do appreciate
both both i really do like you know and
it's like your center is kind of like
but you know like no just say you have
money just say you're you know but i'm
like look don't look me in the eye i
stepped over your dead body for seven
years
like i earned it
like but you know what i mean like i but
i've always felt that way i've always
felt i got you that way like where you
where i i always felt like an outsider
with the rich sure real rich but i don't
know but yeah yeah i can
it's funny there's not much difference
when you think yeah
just nicer houses better clothes yeah
and once you're involved seafood's
fresher seafood's fresher yeah you're
not getting the crab salad from the
subway which you think is a delicacy
that's worth a hundred grand i love it
no they don't make it anymore so if
there's anybody in subways watching
bring back the seafood the light please
oh you would get that oh they did they
do it great i didn't even know they sold
oh they did it i'd rather eat seafood
from the subway
than [ __ ] from a subway let me tell
you something subway seafood salad on a
[ __ ] on a 12 inch [ __ ] wheat roll
with a little mayo and some sweet peps
good night throwing a bag of sun chips
and a dr p yeah they were so big on
sunshine
give me a dorito what are we doing with
the sunshine
get out of here they make you think it's
harvey's chatter hard to get out of it
love what sun chips rule king no it's
like eating a cardboard box the salsa
the sauce is fun the garden salsa is
awesome when those things hit my parents
oh i thought we [ __ ] my dad got a
promotion when those things showed up
out of the grocery store i love seeing
your family cut up that seafood delight
in 12s
[Laughter]
we're eating good tonight kids
i call the end one sun chip each no one
wants the end you want the end i wonder
[Laughter]
no you're eating seafood from subway
that they probably served in an ice
cream scooper
that's part of the fun
it makes it feel like a seafood dessert
you know what i mean
i see you bring it to coldstone you're
like
can you can you kill us have you showed
us a little more can i get the uh crab
with the reese's pizza make a smoothie
yeah if they don't serve in an ice cream
scoop you're getting ripped off you
don't know how much you're getting three
ounces let's go
measure that [ __ ] out
you don't like mashed potatoes served
with an ice cream scoop oh they're
always good mashers why are you ordering
mashed potatoes that come out like that
if you go to like a vfw buffet they got
spaghetti meatballs look how he says
buffet
the guy says buffet like like he's like
uh in an izone shirt yeah
buffet the buffet
yeah real real [ __ ] loose b
buffet
a buffet the buffet yeah so yeah so i
don't even know where we were with that
i don't even know the hamptons oh the
hamptons your brother does good what
about your other brother he was good no
no well they're both my real no i know
that's what i'm saying yeah he's not
randy we're talking about it or jake the
snake
might as well not the captain
the captain's gotta look out of line on
a charter yeah it doesn't seem like a
hamptons kind of guy to me
for like a hampton's inn fella
extended stay
oh so he's got a stove again we stayed
in it we stayed
had a kitchen that we were like yo what
the [ __ ] is this dude
an extended stavery is four hours
get him out of here
no yeah so yeah no my brother like he
was gonna go uh be a doctor but he did
like pre-med and he couldn't figure it
out so he had like organic chemistry so
i was like if he can't do it i'm not
going to be a doctor what did you
attempt it what'd you go to school for i
i cheated on everything i was a finance
major just like your dad two lanes
[Laughter]
after the old man that was one thing it
was one thing and it was my mother
i've never heard of my dad this guy's a
spitting image of his pop huh when in
doubt cheat
and that's when i got to know my dad no
no no yeah so no i would i i majored i
majored in that because my brother went
to tulane too okay major in finance i
was like i'll do finance and be make
everyone happy kind of thing and did you
work in finance after no no no i it's uh
i mean my jobs is a whole nother like
probably hour and a half but i i moved
to i went back to florida i moved to la
to be a pa uh
really shoots for the stars huh
who the [ __ ] moves to l.a i drove across
the country i thought i had a job it was
a weekend it was it was an hour it was a
music video or something it was a waffle
or a ihop with joel mchale ihop
commercial i thought i thought it was
like i thought i had a job for like with
benefits you were going home with joel
yeah yeah so i'm like your guy now huh
i wore a suit i wore a suit no you did
like you're moving boxes and i was like
does that mean i'm getting residuals
i like read a book about production like
a production for like dummies or
whatever dude i did a pa i never i know
i've never done it before i moved up
here and they're like we need someone it
was like a friend worked there i need
someone for the day pays up you know 12
bucks an hour i'm like i'm in and i'm
like i'm doing it it's for a music video
and i'm like what do i have to do just
wait till someone says we need a pa on
the walkie-talkie and then go do
whatever they tell you to do i go okay
so i'm standing there i'm smoking a cig
and all i like just listening like
someone's in the shot i'm like they're
smoking they're like someone's get out
of the shot i'm dude i'm not like i'm
like well they're not saying that
production
i'm sitting there smoking a sink they're
like get you
get out of your smoke and get out of the
shower oh my god the guy who dad doesn't
talk to you your dad's not gonna call
you back next month okay hey single mom
face get out of my shot
i felt like such a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
so i drew again so you know la didn't
work out for me to say the least i
didn't and uh until tuesday it did yeah
well i lived there for like a year and
i'm gonna make it big one day i'll be
making 17 bucks did you start doing
comedy when you get out there no no i
walked by her i lived like an hour and a
half away from west hollywood too i
don't know what i was doing and then i
lived in hermosa i'd walk past the
hermosa comedy club and i was like one
day i'll walk you know one day i'm gonna
be a pa there yeah yeah
yeah one day i'll do that guy's laundry
and uh no but like yeah so like i
remember i wrote like a little bit like
a scat like uh us a two
about minutes foreskin i was going to
wear a turtleneck on stage
it would have been it would have been
killed the fire would have killed got a
real carrot top over here
[Laughter]
wait you're not circumcised never really
what
yeah i'm surprised
some big pieces take like 400 and make a
look you got to do something with them
so so anyways so yeah so i lived in la i
ended up uh
long story short i i i go to new orleans
and uh to hang out with friends and i
end up doing too much blow
believe it or not and uh believe it
actually no we believe you i never
bought cocaine okay in my life ever i
did it like probably like 15 times to
this date yeah to this day wow i'm
surprised at that yeah and uh but i did
a lot that night okay with a stripper
okay overlooking lake pontchartrain
talking about life we weren't even
[ __ ] we weren't no dick was hard no
[ __ ] was wet it was just hey what what
is life you know and next thing i know i
did a a gravity bomb hit you know what
you know that is like when they cut
short yeah yeah and um nick and then my
body went numb i couldn't move my arms
and uh i thought i was having a heart
attack or a stroke and i had my buddy
driving the er
then i spent three days in the er in the
heart ward okay blood thinner put in my
stomach eight grand ran up a bill and i
was like oh maybe i'll go back to
florida you know like like that's when i
decided i mean it was you know i was in
great shape then did you go back to your
moms went back to my mom's moved into my
mom's i was uh i was living there i had
no idea what i was gonna do and uh i
remember i found this like note or this
letter that was written to me from a
girl on a cruise from a cruise like
years before and i was like oh this is
why i had the coke overdose and
failed to find this girl and then was i
hit her up on facebook she wanted
nothing to do with me and so then
you talk about pretty woman yeah real
fairy tale yeah yeah pacino uh so
anyways so i end up uh i get it i do
real estate real estate was booming then
yeah so i got a real estate lineup so
many dirt bags try to get into real
estate bro oh all my clothes were
cleaned up huh are
bro i i made 300 grand overnight like so
so
i [ __ ] i had no money right i'm in
debt i just got a drug a mild overdose
and then i end up getting my real estate
license on the second try and then i end
up uh
you know with the first one i was like
wow this is hard
you know first one was to take the
pictures of the test
so i ended up
this one is to steal a scantron
of course it's just i'm just chasing the
joint it's like ocean's eleven but it's
like so sad it's like yeah um oh you
just have to write c uh
so i get my license and um and i'm like
trying to sell houses and i don't know
what the [ __ ] to do and then my buddy
rusty the third
uh a good friend from high school he's
actually a labrador
have you seen airbud
he's a cancer sniffer
i love a dog that does real estate it's
so great
[Laughter]
shit's all over the living room but get
you a hell of a mortgage
we're gonna have to get a reasoning what
do you think sport
stop prime rusty stop wiping your ass on
the floor rusty the best is when a dog
talks
and says english but also in a dog for
like yeah
dude anytime anytime animals do human
things i [ __ ] love it i do love it
forget about it so and then like yeah so
he's like we should sell land so then
there was these orange groves that were
i had no idea but he put he figured it
out you put together some parcels and
you sell them to home builders that
would clear the land and build
so this was like the height of the
market so we had it under con we got um
six parcels under contract okay who paid
for the actual parcels so this we found
this buyer from south florida right so
he had this i saw his pro forma you know
what those are you know numbers things
anyway whatever it just shows what
you're gonna prob probably earn from
profits right and it was like insanely
high and i was like then the guy got
cancer i was gonna buy it wanted a
partner so they were gonna back out and
so i had my uncle big in real estate in
chicago come down he bought it yeah for
like 7.8 million next thing i know i get
cut a check for like 280 thousand
dollars
i'm just like okay this is uh pretty
cool you know you've never had any kind
of money like that before in your life
no no not at all it was a production
assistant for a weekend yeah yeah what
do you mean this good man joel mccall
wasn't paying like that oh it did not
end well it did not end well at all so
then i ended up doing it one other deal
i make like 90 grand and then we had
that deal under contract for 7.8 for
16.1 to a homebuilder so everything was
like perfect you know i was just gonna
make another like literally million
dollars like literally a million oh wait
why would you get paid yeah get paid for
the flip too oh okay and because we
found the buyer too and so next thing
you know the market starts to get a
little worse i'm like nah but you know
we're buying bottles i bought a tundra
like a truck but you know how that's he
bought a toyota tundra yeah drop it
right there
he's dropping that like it's jaguar
so i got the tundra out back but you
don't have to give any of the 300 grand
back right
no not that did your tundra have that
extended cab gate that like an extended
stay
the tun just had that never mind no i
get what you're saying yeah i get
everything it was 42 g's i put i put
rims on i put like 22s on it and not
spinners but they just sat still but um
that's insane and then i traded in the
truck for a mercedes with my used car
dealer friend named jack hardy go see
him on us1 and vero good guy you want to
get arrested still wet my beak a little
bit
i still i still get a couple of points
if i send anybody at all wait did the
was the parcel is a legitimate thing
like like you know yeah they were 60
acres of orange like has that been
developed in the real estate so this is
where it gets fun your uncle doesn't
talk to you anymore i'm still on the
hook do you know any buyers
and that's the podcast i think you guys
figured
this is like that's why i invited you
here you know you gotta find five
true detectives
you start smoking fully you know you're
a smart guy yeah yeah you burned a few
bridges in your day you know when a
bridge is burned uh so no yeah i still
need 50 for staying at the place it was
one thing i forgot
uh
so anyway so i ended up uh yeah the
market just kept getting worse and worse
and we keep spending more and more money
i bought a condo for like 220 grand oh
by the way i traded in the truck for
mercedes yeah yeah amg and i threw seven
grand in cash at his face in a brown bag
it was the best day of my life because i
had to like split the difference it felt
great
i love it this guy's nuts yeah so then i
end up losing everything right so my my
house went from 220 thousand it was like
six pulled up here on a bike to your
brother wait how much it was worth
i didn't think you saw the tundra or the
amg buddy
they're in my [ __ ] parking garage
up here in a wave runner dude
you got a dock where do i put this
you guys got bumpers for this thing
so so i end up uh i don't know yeah so
we ended up losing everything my house
went from 220 to like 60 000. did you
have one of those mortgages too like
also your mortgage was ridiculously high
no but these mortgages but the house he
was he had a two hundred thousand dollar
mortgage for a house that's not worth
sixty thousand yeah wow so i had to
short sell it and it's funny when you
short sell a house
they give you like eighteen hundred
dollars like you did it like like it's
supposed to like i already put 40 grand
into it you know how much did you end up
selling the house for 60.
you sold it for 60. yeah like 60 000.
and did you get any of that money i got
it 1800. holy [ __ ] yeah that's it i
thought that was yeah bonuses yeah
pancakes on the brain what are you just
he literally just explained all the
numbers i didn't know that so you sold
it for what 16. someone you looked at
the pro forma what was that i didn't
know that was all he got yeah so that's
all i got and uh then i was in debt
whatever i can't really talk about that
fair enough yeah and then uh but the 300
doesn't add up
he's like you said it was 112
mockingbird way yeah no it was actually
a old yukon which i traded in because i
would pay less payments but the gas
money really got me on that which wasn't
smart i wasn't i'm not as smart i'm not
good with money you know i started i
started with a jet ski you know
my brother [ __ ] took his bar mitzvah
money most people bought disney stock
you know my brother like made 9 million
off of whatever so um yeah so anyway so
i lost everything and then
uh
i was in debt and i mean really the
story go then i went then i moved to new
york for a while i thought i would be a
screenwriter i tried to write a movie
that's when i was like i'll be creative
was it the story of you
you would think no it was about laughers
for hire like it was just some random
right but you know
about a scumbag from florida
it was the dumbest movie you've ever and
i sent it to a buddy and he's just like
who worked for like a big production
company in la he's like this is listen
but i need a pa this weekend if you can
make it out to california i'll drive
i'll drive can i borrow a car
because mine just got really just a
yukon
so yeah so i ended up moving here worked
for my brother for a while that didn't
work out had a panic attack in the
middle of night i was working in ohio in
ohio for his one of his companies so
they like buy manufacturing companies
and flip them after they make them run
better and then fire everyone and then
sell them for more money
and uh i was working in a factory with a
hard hat on i'm like i'm just trying to
be a creative here you know how do i
have a heart and i just had a panic
attack i was working in that shift
went back to florida
and then working for like a company
called nurse on call where i because my
dad's a doctor and
it was at home nursing which cancer
patients need to have sure and um
so anyways long story short then i got
into comedy at 30. i will say this
though there is something to be said for
that because i've had that that moment
too and i think that's how you know
you really want to do it is when you are
in the regular life and you have the
hard hat on and then all of a sudden you
have that moment where you're like oh my
god i don't want to be here so bad
this is so far yes from what i feel
inside what i should be doing with my
life that's a that's a scary moment you
need it but that's a [ __ ] that's a
that's a you know you never want to go
back you know what i mean you know okay
i'm gonna do whatever it takes to get to
to get to do this i think so i think
that
also it's like every job i ever had was
nepotism or some form of like
a connection a connection and i'm very
lazy you know i've always was lazy and
stand up you can't you really want you
have to earn it yeah you got to earn it
yeah and it felt good to [ __ ] earn it
you know sure yeah it felt like sports
again or like something that like oh
[ __ ] it's very merit based yeah it
really is and uh yeah so i my buddy had
a divorce and uh his wife left him for
like some guy with a big dick and uh so
then they wrote they bought him at the
uh a comedy class the right joke talking
about his shitty ex-wife and then he
bought he's like you gotta take this
class at the improv and so he paid for
this class this is in florida this was
in florida in west palm beach huh and
that's how i started in stand-up damn
i moved to new york like a year later
and then yeah
that's pretty much yeah and now as a dog
walker for six years
you know why you were pursuing stand up
why was pursuing stand up but he never
had that feeling
of with the hard hat on again
i mean i would say that feeling came
every day i picked the dog [ __ ] yeah
i think there's something more to life
here
at least you know you're moving in the
right direction though uh yeah yeah at
first i mean you moved to new york we
all like romanticize it right right
right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right right right so it's also at least
you're surrounded by comedians you're
doing some sort of shows and stuff
you're like but i'm in the world i'm
doing this is a means to an end right it
is brutal i wouldn't that's listen we
did five years in philly that was like
kind of fun we were crazy but it was
kind of fun and you know it it had like
a you know you feel like it felt
different but here i would not i would
you could take as many years off my life
as you want i would never want to go
back and do those first three years oh
yeah yeah
[ __ ] it it just sucked i mean it was fun
it sucked yeah you drank a lot of
chocolate thank god we're naive tinder
and hit exactly you gotta be naive
yeah i mean do you remember i remember
showing you tinder off front of the
villagers drinking beers you're like
wait so these are all just girls around
here
i said yeah if you like if you go to
swipe you don't want to be honest
you don't have to just wait by the docks
yeah right
no but yeah so yeah i mean yeah you just
you you get motivation from doing
something that
your family doesn't think it's pi i
remember my dad i was like i want to be
a stand-up oh sure and he said something
to me he goes uh he goes yeah i wanted
to play third base for the yankees
which is a great line yeah and he
remembers saying it i actually don't
even like really remember he said it to
me he's like i think he came up with it
later but no but like i think
yeah he just no but like that's like
you know so yeah so yeah damn in new
york and then i'm walking a dog and
nikki glazer takes a photo of me picking
up dog [ __ ]
and then my life kind of changed from
that day because i was walking a dog
with wheels
that's insane
i'm walking a dog with wheels and you
didn't know it takes a photo i don't
know i met her maybe once yeah she
didn't know me yeah yeah she thought i
was the owner of this [ __ ] lazy dog
who [ __ ] doesn't use his back legs
and uh
and um
and she puts it on instagram and then
one of my buddies like ryan beck or
something i was like oh that's tagged me
and was like yo that's a comic she
follows me that day she doesn't live in
new york at this time she's just
visiting then a couple years later she
moves to new york and she's like you're
probably not still dog walking i'm like
no i [ __ ] am i i am i'm actually i
sniff tumors now i am a dog okay i got
another wave runner i gotta pay for it
what do you got make go with the cash
and she [ __ ] hires me as her dog
walker and the first [ __ ] day i meet
her i'm telling you you know i i open up
to be let me see how i am but like and
she's like well why don't you host for
me at caroline's first day i meet her
within the first hour there you go
and then it kind of just right we i
walked your dog twice a day
we became friends then she had me on the
radio show right and it just all like
but i was ready you know yeah yeah yeah
yeah you're kind of you know i had a
very good showing at carolina sure which
was scary because caroline we all do
caroline's it's like on a wednesday and
there's four people just 500. so then
you go in there and it's like [ __ ]
sold out on a thursday and i just i'm
like my jokes work yeah you know
and it was [ __ ] yeah and it was all
like yeah it's kind of crazy how it all
like kind of
came and then covet hit and now we're
now broke again yeah yeah but like no
but things are you know finally moving
in the right direction i guess that's a
hell of a [ __ ] tale right there
brother a hundred percent
yeah garbage garbage
oh i didn't even i didn't even get into
like all my garbage stores like
i could go on for days about that was
something else horrible things i've done
you got anything you want to ask this
guy well i mean i think we should run
through a couple of questions at least
get some yes or no's you know what i
mean let's find out did i talk too much
no no that was [ __ ] beautiful
fantastic
where are you living now so i [ __ ]
lived in bushwick in the middle of you
know nowhere for [ __ ] six years right
and because thousands of people died
thank god i got to afford
an apartment in the city i got a
penthouse on 48.
i'm actually your landlord jerk off give
me the money
no i gotta i moved out i got my own
place that's great nice on uh seventh
and well actually i shouldn't say yeah
but like in like noho area nice
it's the best thing i mean when you live
in this it's like changes your life sure
i mean whatever yeah we moved to a two
bedroom and you it does change your life
yeah in like a weird way i mean that's
also because
we're not living you know i mean we're
crawling through you know i'm sleeping
on your floor you're dealing with a guy
sleeping on your floor when you have a
little bit of breathing room and a
little bit of this a little bit of that
i mean you feel
you feel like you know you don't feel
like a [ __ ] cockroach yeah yeah
people are always like you know
new york you must [ __ ] someone i am
[ __ ] for like six years because i was
a dog walker and i had no self-esteem
yeah i just got the bike yeah
yeah my brother doesn't even know i have
it
all right let's hit him with a couple of
the patreon questions uh
all right well let's do some of the
basics okay let's run through some of
the basics do you brush your teeth in
the shower
i do
of course you do because you're a
[ __ ] scumbag and you're the only one
that ever say it like that with a huge
smile we just handed you an award yeah i
do thank you so much
he just gave him an emmy yeah yeah
i just want to thank
everyone that got me somebody no i
[ __ ] i have i'm not the best brusher
i've been known to not i didn't brush my
tongue for 15 years i didn't know you
even do that so apparently you brush
your tongue
i i i put it in the shower it's another
step
of washing sure now i don't even think
about it i want my breath anyways you
keep your toothbrush in the shower i do
why who's against this you are yeah
what do you do you do it i do everything
in the shower okay that's why it's gross
to brush your teeth in the shower my
girlfriend i eat ham sandwich
that's right keep the eggs
growing up did you drink milk with
dinner
no
yeah
[Laughter]
still as a 45 year old man that's just
because you're jewish that's why you
didn't drink milk with them no because
no i don't ever really like in a [ __ ]
i'm not like in the hoosiers movie you
don't [ __ ] drink milk unless you
listen live next to a corn shoot
shooting
shooting free throws in the dark yeah
you're like it gets you vitamin d
that's what my dad would tell me all
right
um growing up did your parents keep your
mom keep the butter on the counter or in
the refrigerator
it's a good question in the refrigerator
did you guys have a garage fridge
growing up you have a second
refrigerator we did but we had a shark
in the garage
we had a my brother caught a shark
very easily what are you talking about
my brother got a nurse shark an eight
and a half foot shark uh it was a what
in captiva which is on the west coast of
florida biggest nurses work ever caught
in canada whatever what was
no but it was stuff so every day i if i
had to go get a drink in the garage i
had to walk past we named it herb
because uh the guy that uh
nice jewish name he tapped into that
boat
brother he he died like two weeks
afterwards at sea
he like fell into the ocean or something
i don't know exactly what happened and
so we honored him instead of you know
buying a bench we just named a shark
kept it real fast so every day i'd go oh
we got the shark i mean you might as
well name them what was in this
refrigerator
juices sodas beers beers uh back then
i'm feeling
there weren't many options back then
with drinks i maybe some cokes okay you
know some sprite
you know it's respectable there wasn't
like v8 or like [ __ ] gator maybe
gatorades maybe gatorades back there
yeah well i remember the v8
v8
my stepdad that [ __ ] ain't classic oh
that's like drinking tomato soup that
stuff sucks bro v8 is disgusting i
remember my indian friends would drink
it and i'd be like that's why you smell
jesus jesus christ what the [ __ ] there
was no not because i'm not generalizing
that skin smell
it was frank all right his name was
doctor doctor
i'm not even kidding he was a doctor
with the last name doctor anyways um
i got a couple of random ones here have
you ever gone tubing down a river yes
yeah come on it's a real trash at his
dad's wedding what do you mean
that's how she came in and she said she
came in
i'm sure jake was probably the leader of
that my good friends pushed me i was
like i don't really want to go down this
river they're like no it's fun uh have
you ever had a chain wallet
no but i had a
velcro
wallet
that's pretty cool it was like a no fear
or something what was it probably yeah
they had some no fear shirts big dog big
red dog ah the big dogs uh no fear
absolutely it was another big one like
absolute party man or absolute uh
football why can't i think guy harvey's
a big florida shirt yeah if we saw you
that's all that's a fish my step that's
all my stepdad wears this guy harvey
t-shirts
if we saw you as a kid it's all [ __ ]
guy harvey what's the other one though
not no fear a big johnson big dude if
you if you were walking in your chat in
the 90s with a big johnson t-shirt you
were 100 so if we saw you as a kid we
would know you were a florida kid you're
telling us right now would you like what
were you had
what about the puka shells you wear
those a little bit but no i had a hemp
necklace for a while during my day
period i'm gonna
have frosted tips
uh i did dye my hair blonde but it just
came out orange but not like i never
took 80 years when that hit that was big
for a lot of people yeah i was like 18.
it wasn't as a kid but yeah yeah you
mentioned dave matthews did you follow
him on tour at all i went to like
probably three concerts i loved dave i i
had a dave moment i used to like listen
to [ __ ] dave and cry in a bunk bed
you know
have you ever done nitrous
i have done nitrous but i didn't do it
in florida i did in new orleans this
place they call them easy beats you go
into this record store and you go ahead
a little bit easy and a little cracker
yeah it was such a stupid it's the
probably the dumbest my buddy uh shut up
well probably heroin
or oxy but he was like a mechanic and he
had a license where he could go get oh
forget it the big tanks so like he could
go fill up like a [ __ ] five-foot tank
and dude at one point like he would just
like we'd be like at the bar he would
like pull up we're like dude you're just
doing this on like a tuesday like what
the [ __ ] where is that guy now where's
that guy we got appetizers coming he
ain't listening i know that much
i mean it's just so fun to have a tank
it's like your own keg it's like oh dude
he would roll around with it like yo i
got the yeah i got the tank yeah you
just keep hitting it we had one in our
fraternity house oh a tank yeah of
course always there was always a tank
they were always outside those kind of
concerts there would be one guy with a
horse yeah yeah [ __ ] five dollar
balloons that acid weed [ __ ] like
acid goo balls yeah oh goo balls they
were [ __ ] i've never done them but you
just all like once my friends get into
dave and face
peanut butter like peanut butter and
acid or mushrooms or something i
remember this hippie we went to a fish
concert in new orleans i was with all my
fraternity friends and and this hippie
came up and he's like
hey man if you want any goo balls or
like no and he's like man he's like and
he's like almost crying he's like the
cops got my friend
the cops got my friend man
they beat him up real bad and my buddy
looks at him he goes you ever thought
about joining a fraternity
and the guy's like so [ __ ] up he's
just like like like you did it
he's like pie cap alpha would love you
yeah it was so [ __ ] what's your gpa
like this year yeah are you in any
extracurricular activities yeah they
really like that on a resume i like
these questions these like florida
redneck um have you i guess you probably
put a sound system in your car
of one of the cars
you would think you went rims but no
sound system yeah i can't the tundra
came with a pretty good system yeah yeah
yeah yeah had a couple of good six by
nines i never put a woofer in or
whatever
wall street uh any male family members
uh uncles cousins ever have a ponytail
probably not the step family step oh
yeah that family jake seemed like a baby
did you ever have to call the cops on
anybody in the family
uh
there were some nights that got
interesting um my
i don't know my mom my stepmom called
the cops on my dad but then she got
arrested which is pretty cool
my dad came down in a t-shirt that
somehow went past his face
she got arrested yeah it was pretty
awesome and then my step-brother
actually used my i got a uh my my dad
got me a truck uh dodge uh whatever
anyways but my brother before i ever
even got it drove the truck to get
mushrooms
you just pick them off the cow [ __ ] wow
yeah you get him yourself back in the
day and he got arrested cops came
and for stealing mushrooms yeah because
you're trespassing geez and he ended up
getting off but yeah but yeah no there
were a few times where he was i got
arrested a couple times okay yeah i
could imagine
uh i got one more anyone in your family
assuming step side of the family is
anyone into
taxidermy
well
you got the shark
yeah i guess i guess you're into it you
don't remember herb
what's wrong with you
the nurse the nurse shark slash
accountant yeah we had a snake we had a
snake my brother bought a burmese python
then went to college and left the snake
this you don't leave a snake wait is it
your brother or step brother my brother
my older brother was in the living room
you guys are the weirdest jews i've ever
met yeah we're just crazy we're like
redneck jesus yeah yeah which is not a
mixture come by a lot dude i got
arrested for speeding
yeah that's a real thing you hear that
what i got i got arrested for speeding
on a jet ski in a manatee zone you don't
know this story it was right by foley's
house we should end probably on this
story it's a good story i got i i got
caught on like new uh it was like july
4th had some fake titty girl on the back
of this jet ski i'm rolling going like
85 and a five you know no wake zone i
don't know that was speed limits on the
ocean there is
okay yeah yeah yeah so so i get pulled
over i'm hammered they don't give me a
bui then they just give me a ticket
that's a b-u-i boating underground oh
you're [ __ ] or a jew
jet skiing
you're a [ __ ] jew no they're like no
you're getting arrested so anyway so
so then six months later i'm out on a
date you are garbage with a stripper
okay i swear to god with an orlando's
well we believe you you don't have to
he's like i swear to god me
this guy right here who just just
described being a garbage i know you're
not gonna believe this yeah so six
months later i'm on a date with this
stripper right she's gorgeous she looks
like shakira i swear to god she's like
the hot she doesn't speak any english
she just keeps going you're so nice you
know stopped feeling like a compliment
when it was the only word she knew and
uh she's like yeah
i think he's so nice yeah so nice on the
rocks
and then i was like so we end up i'm
she's the hottest honestly one of the
hottest women i've ever [ __ ] met in
my life
i take her home she lives in like kind
of a shitty part of orlando
and we're making out
though keeps telling her yeah
dude the more you talk the more you
might be jake the snake when i start
saying
if you have me start talking about
florida
get down there underneath the mangrove i
said this ain't no manatees huh i take
it down to our orlando right yeah you
know it's all hot down there i mean it's
pretty cold it's pretty nice uh a cold
desert florida stinks yeah it's pretty
cool
[Laughter]
so so so i'm dropping her off and the
cop rolls behind my car and and shines
[ __ ] the light in the car gets on the
speakers like yeah step out her vehicle
step out her vehicle have your hands up
and i look at her
you know tell them i'm nice you know and
uh i'm just like will you like put a
good word put in a good word and and i
get out and he's like
uh hands behind your back what the [ __ ]
he's like you have a warrant now for
your arrest
i'm like what do i have like what he's
like were you uh and i swear to god he's
laughing like he can't believe what's
coming through he goes did you uh were
you uh speeding on a jet ski uh in a
manatees with a big titty girl
with a big titty girl big titty broad on
your uh yamaha zx4 did you know you got
a ticket for that when they wrote you up
yeah but i was hammering i never paid
the ticket he was living life he had a
big titty brought on a [ __ ] jet ski
you know what he didn't even have
pockets he's got a bathing suit he's not
worried about the environment he's gonna
do it with the ticket no it was like an
80 ticket and i was like can i just pay
it now he's like yeah you could pay it
now and i was like i don't have cash on
he's like well you're going
i was like can we stop at an atm i'll do
it behind my back i'll do whatever you
want and so then this is the best like i
noticed his last name was like hernandez
and i was like oh you speak spanish will
you tell my beautiful like the most
beautiful girl i've ever gone out with
who just said i was the nicest guy can
you ask her for 60 bucks
and then she ends up i go will you like
you know talk to her and let her know
that i'm not you know a murderer and i
don't know what he said to her nothing
uh that [ __ ] told you she ran yeah she
yeah he probably said look i'll [ __ ] you
dude here's my address i won't send you
back
yeah yeah yeah i think she was worried
about getting yeah deported deported or
she loved manatees
i don't know what it was it was one or
the other so then so then now i'm in
[ __ ] the cop car and i'm like i can't
believe you i'm yelling at the cop like
such white privilege i'm like how could
you like you know
he's like and he's like
being nice you know he's like look i'll
get you ahead of people i apologize i
know this is an absurd reason to go to
jail blah blah blah and you [ __ ] blocked
me that's what i sweat and we were
laughing about that i swear to god we
were laughing about me being him being a
[ __ ] block and i don't think he said
yeah i'm gonna put you in the front of
the line i think he would [ __ ] i think
when he dropped me off he's not the dmv
i'll put you in the front of the line
he's like oh you're dr colin's son
it's not a table of joe's crap
yeah
you're waiting so tuesday rolls around
so they blew me so they put me in i
[ __ ] went into a jail cell and i'm
there with like two like badass
[ __ ] and i'm all scared what'd
you get what are you into that's exactly
what happened they were like what's you
know i killed you know i murdered a guy
i [ __ ] robbed what did you do i was
like [ __ ]
and i wanted to lie but then i was like
i couldn't think of i was speeding on a
jet ski real fast
should have seen me i was doing like 40.
i was zooming dude you should have
[ __ ] seen me and the [ __ ] pigs got
it so i was so scared i thought they
were gonna rape and kill me like what a
[ __ ] and the guy goes i swear to god to
this day he goes was it a yamaha or
kalasaka
and i swear to god i go it was yamaha
oh that's a good ski
that's cool that's a good personal
watercraft put the throat slitter away
we're gonna let this one live if i said
kawasaki boy who knows you know
and that was like yeah so i mean that
was a very florida story i mean i got
out the next morning but
yeah it was uh
that's kind of where my life was at you
are trash ladies and gentlemen mr andrew
collins you might steal the [ __ ] you
might take the take the cake for the
most scratchiest guest ever oh you're up
there you guys are you guys are great at
this by the way
i'm not just trying to kiss your ass but
like this was a lot of fun
is there anything you want the folks out
there to know what you got coming up
check out the podcast yeah my podcast
puddles with andrew colin i really just
have uh women on there so if you want to
jerk off to the internet go to my
youtube and just look at the women that
i interview it's pretty cool being
pretty classy right till the end of the
show
it's so funny i was like when he first
came in i'm like oh he's trash and then
he's like and then i thought he i
thought he was gonna be a nice jewish
boy and then he turns out to be a
[ __ ] redneck hillbilly from the
panhandle yeah i didn't know we were
walking into this this is crazy dude i
got a shower
uh guys make sure you rate review
subscribe call my dad
i love him
i'm gonna try i don't think he i think
he changed his number though that still
love you uh
kev ryan zero uh cameron comedy on all
social media guys please make sure you
rate review subscribe on itunes full
video available on youtube you can get
bonus episodes every week multiple
episodes a week by me and h foley on
patreon.com are you garbage we're having
fun sign up you can support the [ __ ]
show you can help us keep the lights on
pay to rent um and also podcast merge go
grab a t-shirt and this uh game should
be available uh uh are you garbage you
can play at your house with your friends
it's gonna be awesome uh we love you
guys uh andrew what do you got on social
media uh andrew t colin on instagram and
then uh yeah everything's there very
nice tobester toby mcmullen everybody
t-bone
at toby dot mcmullen on instagram check
it out boo-boo excellent nh fully on ice
on twitter foldygrams on instagram give
us a follow give us a rate and review
the whole nine yards and come see us
december 10th at seoul joel's me and
kippy will be down there royer's fourth
great pennsylvania yeah i heard it i did
it i did it it's great get some [ __ ]
tick seven o'clock show it's gonna be
nice come down and see us
peace peace